The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So this
is the outline of
the lecture for today.
So we just need to talk about
the conditional densities for
Poisson process.
So these are the things that
we've seen before in previous
sections, so I'm just going to
give a simple proof for them
and some intuition.
So if you remember the Poisson
process, this was the famous
figure that we had.
So our time is at zero and
afterwards zero and then we
had some arrivals.
So our time is then t.
We had N of t arrivals,
which is equal to n.
This is Sn.
This is the figure
that we had.
So for the first equation,
we're looking at--
We want to find the conditional
distribution of
interval times condition
and last arrival times.
So first of all, we want to find
the joint distribution of
the interval arrival
times and the last
arrival, this equation.
So you know that interval
arrival times are independent
in the Poisson process, so just
looking at this thing,
you know that these things are
independent of each other so
we will have lambda to
the power of Ne to
the power minus lambda.
And then, this last one
corresponds to the fact that
xn plus 1 is equal to n plus
1 minus summation of x.
These two events are equivalent
to each other, so
this is going to correspond
to lambda e to the
power of minus lambda.
So we just did it the
other way, so
it's going to be like--
So you can just get rid of these
terms and it's going to
be that equation.
So it's very simple, it's
just the independence of
inter-arrival times.
So you look at the last term as
the inter-arrival time for
the last arrival, and then
they're going to be
independent, and the terms kind
of cancel out and you
have this equation.
So this conditional density
will be the joint
distribution--
or the distribution of Sn plus
1, which is like these.
So the joint decision
will be like this.
So what does the intuition
behind this mean?
This means that--
you've seen this term before.
This means that we have uniform
distribution over the
interval of zero to one,
condition on something.
So previously, what we had was
the conditional distribution
of arrival times condition on
the last arrival, so F of s1
and condition on sn plus 1.
But here we have distribution
of x1 to x and
condition on sn plus 1.
And previously, the constraint
that we had was like we should
have ordering over the
arrival times.
So because of this constraint
we had this n factorial, if
you remember, that order of
statistics things that you
talked about.
Now here, what we have is
something like this.
So all the arrival times
should be positive, and
summation of them should
be less than t.
Because well, the summation
of them to n plus 1 is
equal to sn plus 1.
And the last term is positive,
so this thing should
be less than t.
So these two constraints are
sort of dual to each other.
So because of this constraint,
I had some n factorial over
the conditional distribution of
arrival times, condition on
the last arrival time.
Now, I have inter-arrival
conditional distribution of
inter-arrival time condition
on last arrival time and we
should have this n
factorial here.
The other interesting thing is
that if I condition it under n
of t, so the number of arrivals
at time [INAUDIBLE]
t.
The time is going to be very
similar to the previous one.
Just to prove this thing,
it's very simple again.
I just wanted to show you--
So what does this thing mean?
This thing means that these are
the distributions of the
inter-arrival times and the last
event corresponds to the
fact that xn plus 1 is bigger
than t minus summation of xi.
Because we have an arrival
time at [? snn, ?]
and then after that there's
no arrival.
Because at time nt we
have n arrivals.
So this corresponds
to do is thing.
So again, we'll have something
like lambda n, e
to the power of--
This is for the first event
and you see that these are
independent because of the
Poisson properties of the
Poisson process.
And the last term will be--
property of the Poisson
and a variable bigger
than something is--
Yes, this cancel out.
And then we'll have this term,
this first n lambda to the
power of n, just forget
about n plus 1.
And property distribution of n
of t equal to n is this term
without n plus 1.
So lambda n to the 12, and e
to the power minus lambda t
over n factorial.
So these terms cancel out and
we'll have this thing.
So again, we should have these
constraints that summation of
xk, k equal to 1, n should
be less than t.
No matter if they are
conditioning of n of t or sn
plus 1, the last arrival time
or the number of arrivals at
some time instant, the condition
of distribution is
uniform subject to
some constraints.
Is there any questions?
So if you look at the limit, and
so again, looking at this
figure, you see that this
corresponds to sn plus 1 and
you see that sn plus
1 is bigger than t.
So if you take the limit and
take the t1 going to t, these
two distributions are going
to be the same.
So t1 corresponds
to sn plus 1.
t1.
So basically what's it's saying
is that conditional
distribution of arrival times
are uniform, independent of
what is going to happen
in future.
So in future, there might be
some, I mean, the knowledge
that we have about future could
be the fact that knowing
what happens in this interval
or the next arrival is going
to happen at some point, I
mean, condition on these
things the arrival times are
going to be uniform.
The other fact is that this
distribution that I showed
you, they are all symmetric
with respect to interval
arrival times.
So it doesn't matter, I mean,
no arrival has more priority
to any other one or they're not
different to each other.
So if you look at the
permutation of them, they're
going to be similar.
So now, I want to look at the
distribution of x1 or s1, they
are equal to each other.
I can easily calculate the
probability of x1 bigger than
some tau condition, for example,
n of t is equal to n.
So what is this conditional
distribution?
So condition on n of t equal
to n, I know that in this
interval I have n arrivals and
n inter-arrival times, and I
want to know if x1 is in
this interval, or s1.
s1 is equal to x1.
And you know that si's
are also uniform.
So you know that these are
independent of each other, and
so you can say that the
probability of this thing is
like this one.
So all of them should
be bigger than tau.
And since this is symmetric--
so this corresponds to x1.
Since this was--
everything was symmetric for
all inter-arrival times.
This is also the complimentary
distribution function for xk.
Is there any questions?
So the other think that are not
in the slides that I want
to tell you is the conditional
distribution of
si given n of t.
So I know that there n arrivals
in this interval, and
I want to see if the i arrival
is something like this.
So the probability that--
so this even corresponds to
the fact that there is one
arrival in this interval and i
minus 1 arrival was here and n
minus i minus 1 arrival
was here.
Oh, no, sorry, n minus
i arrival is here.
So the probability of
having one arrival
here corresponds to--
since arrival times our uniform,
and I want to have
one arrival in this interval
like this, and I want to have
i minus arrivals here i minus
one arrivals here, and n minus
i arrivals here.
So it's like aq binomial
probability distribution so
out of the n arrival-- n minus
1 remaining arrivals, I want
to have some of them in
this interval and
some of them here.
So this is the distribution
of this thing.
Yeah, so just as a check
we know that the last
inter-arrival--
last arrival time,
the distribution
of that thing is--
Here, you just cancel these
things out, too--
is--
We need to get back to this
equation, but it's just the
same as this one but you
let i equal to n.
This is OK?
Just to think i equal to
n, you get this one.
AUDIENCE: Does this equation
also apply to i equals
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, sure.
Yeah, i equal to 1, we will
have nt minus tau.
And if you look at this thing,
so this is a complimentary
distribution function.
You just take to zero
till you get that.
This is just a check of
this formulation.
Yeah.
So is there any other
questions?
Did anybody get why we have
this kind of formulation?
Is was very simple, it's just
the combination of a uniform
distribution and a binomial
distribution.
AUDIENCE: What is tau?
PROFESSOR: Tau is this thing.
Tau is the si.
Change of notation.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I said that I want
one arrival in this interval
and i minus 1 arrival was here
and n minus i arrival is here.
So I define it, the
Bernoulli process.
So priority of falling in
this interval is tau
over t minus tau.
And I say that--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: OK, so falling in
this interval in a uniform
distribution corresponds
to success.
I want, among n minus 1
arrivals, i minus 1 of them to
be successful and the rest of
them to be [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE]
that one of them should fall
here and the rest of them
should fall here.
Richard?
AUDIENCE: So that's
the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you just get
rid of this dt, that's it.
[? AUDIENCE: Why do ?]
those stay, n over t.
PROFESSOR: Which one?
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
again the first term?
The first term there,
the nd over t?
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK, so I want
to have one interval
definitely here but among
n arrivals I want
them to fall here.
So any one of them
should cancel.
But then i minus 1 of them
should fall here and n minus i
intervals should fall here.
Any other questions?
It's beautiful, isn't it?
There's a problem.
I studied x1 to xn, but what
is the distribution of this
remaining part?
So if I condition on n, nt or
condition on sn plus 1, what
is the distribution of this
one or this one or doing
distribution off all these?
So this is what we're
going to look.
So first of all, I do the
conditioning over sn plus 1,
and I find the distribution
of--
the distribution of x1 to xn
condition on sn plus 1, is
there any randomness in
distribution of xn plus 1?
So this is going to
be sx plus 1.
be xn plus 1.
So if I find a distribution of
x1 to xn condition on this
condition is sn plus 1, it's
very easy to show that xn plus
1 is equal to sn plus 1.
So there's no randomness here.
But looking at the figure,
you see that--
and the distributions, you see
that everything is symmetric.
So I've found the distribution
x1 to xn and I can find xn
plus 1 easily from them.
But what if I find the
distribution of x2 to xn plus
1, condition on this thing, and
then find x1 from them?
So you can say that x1
is equal to xn minus
1 2 to n plus 1xi.
And then we have
this solution.
So it seems that there's no
difference between them and
actually, there's not.
So condition on sn plus 1, we
have the same distribution for
x1 to xn or x2 to xn plus 1.
But there are only n free
parameters because the n plus
1's can be calculated
in your equations.
If you take any n random
variables out of this n plus 1
random variables, we have
the same story.
So it's going to be uniform, our
0 to t for this interval.
So it's symmetric.
Now, the very nice thing is
about n of t, equal t--
[? so ?] n must be equal to n.
So this is easy because we had
these equations, but what if I
call this thing xn star of
n plus 1 and I do the
conditioning over n of t?
So I don't know the arrival time
for n plus 1's arrival
but I do know the number of
arrivals at time [INAUDIBLE]
t.
Condition on that, what is the
distribution for example, for
xn star n plus 1 or x1 to xn?
Again, easily we can say
that it's the same
story, so it's uniform.
So you can take out of x1 to xn
and xn star n plus 1, you
can take n off them and find
the distribution of that.
OK, so the other way to look at
this is that if I find the
distribution of x1 to xn
condition on n of t, I will
have the expect that xs star n
plus 1 is equal to t minus sn,
which is t minus summation
of x to i.
Can anyone of you see this?
Hope so.
Oh, OK.
So again, if I find the
distribution of x1 to xn, I
can find sx star n plus
1 deterministically.
Just as a signage check, you can
find that f of the star of
x-- oh, sorry, f of x star
n plus 1 condition on--
So looking at this formulation
and just replacing everything,
we can't find this thing, and
you can see that this is
similar to this one again.
So this is the distribution
for--
well, this is the distribution
for x1.
So you can find the
density and this
is going to be density.
So what I'm saying is that
x1 has the same marginal
distribution as xn
plus 1 star.
So you can get it with this kind
of reasoning, saying that
the marginal distribution should
be the same or looking
at this kind of formulation.
When you have this distribution
you can find the
distribution of summation of
xi, i equal to 1 to n.
And then you can find--
So t is determined, so
you can just replace
everything and find it.
And you can see that these
two are the same.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the same distribution
that is one?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Condition on nt [INAUDIBLE].
So everything is symmetric
and uniform.
But you can only choose n for
your parameters because the n
plus 1 is a combination
of the--
Right?
So this is the end of the
chapter [INAUDIBLE]
for Poisson process, is there
any problems or any
questions about it?
So let's start the
Markov chain.
So in this chapter we only talk
about the finite-state of
Markov chains.
Markov chains are some processes
that changing
integer-time sense.
So it's like we're quantizing
time and any kind of change
can happen only in an
integer-time sense.
And it's different in this way
from Poisson processes because
we can have the definition of
Poisson processes for any
continuous time, but Markov
chains are only defined for
integer-times.
And finite-state Markov chains
is a Markov chain where states
can be only in a finite set, so
we usually call it 1 to M,
but you can name it in
any way you like.
What we are looking for in
finite-state Markov chains is
the probability distribution of
the next state conditioned
on whatever [? history ?]
that I have.
So I know that at integer times
there can be some change.
So what is this change?
We model it with the probability
distribution of
this change corresponding
to the history.
So we can model any discrete
integer time
processing this way.
Now, the nice thing about Markov
chains or homogeneous
Markov chains is that
this distribution is
equal to these things.
So you see i and j, so i is the
previous state and j is
the state that I want to go in
so the distribution of the
next state condition and all
the history only depends on
the last step.
So even the previous state, the
new state is independent
of all their earlier things
that might happen.
So there's a very nice
way to show it.
So in general, we say
that xn plus 1 is
independent of xn plus 1.
So if I know the periods--
and these things are true for
all the possible states.
So whatever the history in the
earlier process that I had, I
only care about the state that
I was in in previous time.
And this is going to show me
what is the distribution of
next state.
So the two important things that
you can see this in this
formulation is that, first
of all, this kind of
independence, it is true for
all i, j, k, m, and so on.
The other thing is that it's
not time-dependent.
So if I'm in state, the
probability distribution of my
next state is going to be the
same if the same thing happens
in 100 years.
So it's not time-dependent.
That's why we call it
homogeneous Markov chains.
And we can have non-homogeneous
Markov chains,
but there are not many nice
results about them.
I mean, we cannot find
many good things.
And all the information that
we know to characterize the
Markov chain is this kind
of distribution.
So we call these things
transition probabilities.
And something else which is
called initial probabilities,
which tell me that, at time
instance 0, what is the
probability distribution
of the states.
So knowing Markov chains, you
can find that probability
distribution of x1 is equal to
probability of x1 condition
and x0 [INAUDIBLE].
So knowing this thing
and these transition
probabilities, I can kind
the probability
distribution of x1.
Well, very easily,
the probability
of xn is equal to--
sorry.
so you can do this thing
iteratively.
And just knowing the transition
probabilities and
initial probabilities, you
can find the probability
distribution of the states at
any time instant to forever.
Do you see it's very easy?
You just do this thing
iteratively.
So I talked about the
independence and initial.
Yeah, so what we do is, we
characterize the Markov chains
with these set of transition
probabilities
and the initial state.
And you see that these
transition probabilities, we
have, well, m times n minus 1,
free parameters in them,
because the summation of each of
them should be equal to 1.
So for each initial state, I can
have a distribution over
the next step.
So I'm going to talk about
it in the matrix form.
And what we're doing in practice
usually, we assume
the initial state to be
a constant state.
So we usually just define a
state, call it initial state.
Usually, we call it x0.
I mean, it's what's you're going
to usually see if you
want to study the behavior
of Markov chains.
So these are the two ways that
we can visualize the
transition probabilities.
So matrix form is very easy.
So you just look at
the n probability
distributions that you have.
And with Markov chain with n
number of states, you will
have n distributions, each of
them corresponding to the
conditional distribution of next
step, condition of the
present step equal to i.
So i can be anything.
So this was the thing I was
saying, the number of free
parameters.
So I have n distribution, and
each distribution has n minus
1 free parameters, because the
summation of them should be
equal to 1.
So this is the number of free
parameters that I have.
So is there any problem
with the matrix form?
I'm assuming that you've
all been seeing
this sometime before.
Fine?
So the nice thing about matrix
form is that you can do many
nice stuff with them.
We can look at the notes for
them, and we will see these
kinds of properties later.
But you can imagine that just
looking at the matrix form and
doing some algebra over them,
we can get very nice results
about the Markov chains.
The other representation of the
Markov chains is using a
graph, a directed graph in which
each node corresponds to
a state and each arc, or each
edge, corresponds to a
transition probability.
And the very important thing
about graphical model is that
there's a very clear difference
between 0
transition probabilities
and non-0 transition
probabilities.
So if there's any possibility
of going from one state to
another state, we have an
edge or an arc here.
So probability of 10 to the
power of minus 5 is
different from 0.
We have an arc in one case and
no arc in another case,
because there's a chance of
going from this state to the
next state.
And even then, the probability
is 10 to the power of minus 5.
And OK, so we can do a lot of
inference by just looking at
the graphical model.
And it's easier to see some
properties of the Markov chain
by looking at the graphical
models.
We will see these properties
that we can find by looking at
the graphical model.
So this is not really
classification of states, actually.
So there are some definitions,
very
intuitive definitions here.
So there's something called a
walk, which says that this is
an ordered string of the nodes,
where the probability
of going from each node to
the next one is non-0.
So for example, looking at this
walk, you can have the
probability of going from 4 to 4
is positive, 4 to 1, 1 to 2,
2 to 3, and 3, to 2.
So there is no kind of
constraints in the definition
of the walk.
There should be just positive
probabilities in going from
one state to the next state.
So we can have repetition.
We can have whatever we like.
And the number of-- well,
we can find the number
of states for sure.
So what is the maximum number
of steps in a walk?
Or minimum number?
Minimum number of
states is two--
[? one. ?]
So what is the maximum
number of steps?
Well, there's no constraint,
so it can be anything.
So the next thing that
we look is a path.
A path is a walk where there
is no repeated nodes.
So I never go through
one node twice.
So for example, I have this
path, 4, 1, 2, 3.
We can see here, 4, 1, 2, 3.
And now we can say, what
is the maximum number
of steps in a path?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Steps, not states.
PROFESSOR: n minus 1, yeah.
Because you cannot go through
one state twice.
So you have a maximum number
of steps in n minus 1.
And the cycle is a walk in which
the first and last node
is repeated.
So first of all, there's not
a really great difference
between these two cycles,
so it doesn't
matter where I start.
And we don't care about
the repetition and
definition of cycle.
Oh, OK.
Yeah, sorry.
No node is repeated.
So sorry, something was wrong.
Yeah, we shouldn't have any
repetition except for the
first and last nodes.
So the first and last node
should be the same, but there
shouldn't be any repetition.
So what is the maximum number
of steps in this case?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: n, yeah, because we
have an additional step.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You said in a path,
the maximum number of
steps is n minus 1?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I mean, if you have
n equals, like, 6, couldn't
there be 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6?
PROFESSOR: No, it's the
steps, not the states.
So if I have path from 1 to
2, and this is the path.
So there's one step.
Just whenever you're confused,
make a simple model.
It's going to make everything
very, very easy.
Any other questions?
So this is another definition.
We say that a node j is
accessible from i if there is
a walk from i to j.
And by just looking at the
graphical model, you can
verify the existence of
this walk very easily.
But the nice thing, again, about
this thing is what I
emphasized in the
graphical model.
It talks about if there's any
positive probability of going
from i to j.
So if j is accessible from i
and you start at node i,
there's a positive probability
that you will end in node j
sometime in the future.
There's nothing said about the
number of steps needed to get
there, or the probability of
that, except that this
probability is non-0.
It's positive.
So for example, if there's a
state like k, that we have p
of ik is positive and p of kj is
positive, then we will have
p of ij [? too ?] is positive.
So we have this kind
of notation.
I don't have a pointer.
Weird.
So yeah, we have this kind of
my notation. pijn means that
the probability of going from
state i to state j in n steps.
And this is exactly
like n steps.
Actually, this value could
be different for
different number of n.
For example, if we have a Markov
chain like this, p of
131 is equal to 0, but
p of 132 is non-0.
So node j is accessible from i
if pijn is positive for any n.
So we say that j is not
accessible from i if this is 0
for all possible n's.
Mercedes?
AUDIENCE: Are those actually
greater than or equal to?
PROFESSOR: No, greater.
They are always greater
than or equal to 0.
Probability is always
non-negative.
So what want is positive
probability, meaning that
there's a chance that
I will get there.
I don't care how small this
chance is, but it
shouldn't be 0.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
So p to ij, though, couldn't it
be equal to pik, [? pkj? ?]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
So in this case, p132 is
equal to p12, p23,
AUDIENCE: So I guess I'm asking
if p2ij should be
greater than or equal to pfk.
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
No, actually.
You know why?
Because there can exist some
other state like here.
AUDIENCE: Right.
But if that doesn't exist and
there's only one path.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, sure.
But there's no guarantee.
What I'm saying is that Pik is
positive, Pkj is positive.
So this thing is positive,
but it can be bigger.
In this case, it
can be bigger.
I don't care about the quantity,
about the amount of
the probability.
I care about its positiveness,
it's greater than 0.
I just want it to be non-0.
The other thing is that when we
look at pijn, I don't care
what kind of walk I have
between i and j.
It's a walk, so it can have
repetition, it can have
cycles, or it can
have anything.
I don't care.
So if you really want to
calculate pij for n equal to
[INAUDIBLE]
1,000, you should really find
all possible walks from i to j
and add the probabilities
to find this value.
And all the walks
within steps.
Not here.
Let's look at some examples.
So is node 3 accessible
from node 1?
So you see that there's a
walk like this, 1, 2, 3.
So there's a positive
probability of going to state
3 from node 1.
So node 3 is accessible
from 1.
But if you really want to
calculate the probability, you
should also look at the fact
that we can have cycles.
So 1, 2, 3 is a walk.
But 1, 1, 2, 3 is also a walk.
1, 2 3, 2, 3 is also a walk.
You see?
So you have to count all these
things to find the probability
of p13n for any n.
What about state 5?
So is the node 3 accessible
from node 5?
You see that it's not.
Actually, if you're going to
state 5, you never go out.
With [INAUDIBLE]
probability of 1, you
stay there forever.
So actually, no state except
state 5 is accessible from 5.
So is node 2 accessible
from itself?
So accessible means that I
should have a walk from 2 to 2
in some number of steps.
So you can see that we
can have 2, 3, 2,
or many other walks.
So it's accessible.
But as you see, node 6 is not
accessible from itself.
If you are in node 6,
you always go out.
So it's not accessible.
So let's go back to
these definitions.
Yeah, this is what I said, and
I'm emphasizing again.
If you want to say that j is
not accessible from i, I
should have a pijn equal
to 0 for all n.
The other thing is that, if
there's a walk from i to j and
from j to k, we can prove easily
that there's a walk
from i to k.
So having a walk from i to j
means that for some n, this
thing is positive.
So this is i to j.
From j to k, this means
that p of jk, for
some n, this is positive.
So looking at i two k, I can say
that p of i to k, m plus
n, is greater than.
And I have this thing here
because of the reason that I
explained right now, because
there might be other paths
from i to k, except the paths
going through j, or except the
walks that have n steps to get
to j and n steps to get to k.
So we know that, well, we can
concatenate the walks from--
so if there's a walk from i to
j and j to k, we have a walk
from i to k.
So we say that states i and j
communicate if there's a walk
from i to j and from j to i.
So it can go back and forth.
So it means that there's
a cycle from from i
two i or j two j.
This is the implication.
So it's, again, very simple to
prove that if i communicates
with j and j communicates with
k, then i communicates with k.
In order to prove that,
I should assume that i
communicates to j, I need to
prove that there is a walk
from i to k, and I need to prove
that there is a walk
from k to i.
So this means that i
communicates with k.
So these two things can be
proved easily from the
concatenation of the walks
and the fact that i and j
communicate and j and
k communicate.
Now, what I can define
is something
called a class of states.
So a class is called a non-empty
set of states, where
all the pairs of states in a
class communicated with each
other, and none of them
communicate with any other
state in the Markov chain.
So this is the definition
of class.
So I just group the pairs that
can communicate with the state
and just get rid of all those
who do not communicate to the
[INAUDIBLE].
So for defining a class or for
finding a class, or for naming
a class, we can have a
representative state.
So I want to find all the states
that communicate with
each other in a class.
So I can just pick one of the
states in this class and find
all the states that communicate
with this single
state, because if two states
communicate with one state,
then these two states
communicate with each other.
And if there's a state that
doesn't communicate with me,
it doesn't communicate with
anybody else whom I'm
communicating with.
I'm going to prove it now,
just in a few moments.
Just, I want to look at
this figure again.
So first I take state 2 and
find a class that has this
state in itself.
So you see that in this class,
we have state 2 on 3, because
there's only a state 3 that
communicates with 2.
And correspondingly,
we can have class
having state 4 and 5.
And you see that state 1 is
communicating with itself, so
it's a class by itself.
But it doesn't communicate
with anyone else.
So we have this class also.
So next question, why do
we call C4 a class?
So it doesn't communicate
with itself.
If you're in state 6, you go out
of it with probability of
1, eventually.
So why do we call it a class?
Actually, so this is the
definition of the classes.
But we want to have some very
nice property of other classes
which says that we can partition
the states in a
Markov chain by using
the classes.
So if I don't count this case as
a class, I cannot partition
it, because partitioning means
that I should cover the whole
states in the classes.
What I to do is to do some
kind of partitioning in a
Markov chain that I have, by
using the classes, so that I
can have a representative
state for each class.
And this is one way to partition
the Markov chains.
And why do I say it's
partitioning?
Well, it's covering the whole
finite space of the states.
But I need to prove that
there's no intersection
between classes also.
Why is it like that?
So meaning that I cannot have
two classes where there is an
intersection between them,
because if there's an
intersection--
for example, i belongs to
C1 and i belongs to C2--
it means that i communicates
with all the states in C1 and
i communicates with
all states in C2.
So you can say that all states
in C1 communicate with all
states in C2.
So actually, they should
be the same.
And there's only these
states that
communicate with each other.
We have this exclusivity
that's conditional.
So we can have this kind
of partitioning.
Is there any question?
Everybody's fine?
So another definition which
is going to be very, very
important in the future for
us is the recurrency.
And it's actually very simple.
So a state is called recurrent
if for all the states that we
have j is accessible to
i, we also have i is
accessible to j.
So if from some state i, in some
number of states, I can
go to some state j, I can
get back to i from
this state for sure.
And this should be
true for all the
states in a Markov chain.
So if there's a walk from i to
j, there should be a walk from
j to i, too.
If this is true, then
i is recurrent.
This is the definition
of recurrence.
Is it OK?
And if it's not recurrent,
we call it transient.
And why do we call transient?
I mean, the intuition
is very nice.
So what is a transient state?
A transient state says that
there might be some kind of
walk from i to some k.
And then I can't go back.
So there's a positive
probability that I go out of
state i in some way, in
some walk, and never
come back to it.
So it's kind of transitional
behavior.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No, no, with
some probability.
So there exists some
probability.
There is a positive probability
that I go out of
it and never come back.
It's enough for definition
of transience.
So you know why?
Because I have the definition of
recurrence for all the j's
that are accessible from i.
So with probability 1--
oh, OK, so I cannot say
with probability 1.
Yeah, I cannot say probability
of 1 for recurrency.
But for transient behavior,
there exists some probability.
There's a positive probability
that I go out
and never come back.
State 1 is transient.
And state 3, is it recurrent
or transient?
Some idea?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Transient?
What about state 2?
It's wrong, because there should
be something going on
[INAUDIBLE].
So now here, it's recurrent.
Good?
Oh yeah, we have
examples here.
So states 2 and 3 are recurrent,
because the only
state that I can go out from
this state is to themselves.
So they are only accessible
from themselves.
And there's a positive
probability of going from one
to the other.
So they're recurrent.
But states 4 and 5
are transient.
And the reason is here, because
there is a positive
probability that I go out of
state 4 in that direction and
never come back.
And there's no way
to come back.
And state 6 and 1 are
also transient.
State 6 is very, very transient
because, well, I go
out of it in one step
and never come back.
And state 1 is also transient,
because I can go out of it in
this direction and never
be able to come back.
Do you see?
So this is a very, very, very
important theorem, which says
that if we have some classes,
the states in the class are
all recurrent or
all transient.
This is what we are going to
use a lot in the future, so
you should remember it.
And the proof is very easy.
So let's assume that state
i is recurrent.
And let's define Si, all the
states that communicate with
i, that are accessible from i.
And you know that since i is
recurrent, being accessible
from i means that i is
accessible from them.
So if j is accessible from i,
i is also accessible from j.
So we know that i and j
communicate with each other if
and only if j is in this set.
So this is a class.
This is the class
that contains i.
So this is like the class that I
told you, that we can have a
class where this state
i is representative.
And actually, any state in a
class can be representative.
It doesn't matter.
So by just looking at state
i, I can define a class.
The states that are accessible
from i-- and actually, this is
the class that contains i.
So let's assume that there's
a state called k which is
accessible from some j
which is in this set.
So k is accessible from j, and
j is accessible from i.
So k is accessible from i.
But k accessible from i
implies that i is also
accessible from k, because
i is recurrent.
So you think i is accessible
from k?
And you know that j is also
accessible from i because,
well, Si was also a class,
recurrent class.
So you see that j is
also recurrent.
So if k is accessible from j,
then j is also accessible from
k for any k.
So this is the definition
of recurrency.
So what I want to say is that if
i is recurrent and it's in
the same class as j, then
j is recurrent for sure.
And we didn't prove it here,
but if one of them is
transient, them all of them
are transient too.
So the proof is very simple.
I proved that if there is any
state like k that's is
accessible from j, I need
to prove that j is also
accessible from k.
And I proved it like this.
It's easy.
So the next definition that we
have is the definition of the
periodic states and classes.
So I told you that the number of
steps in a walk-- so when I
say that there's a walk from
some state to the other state,
I didn't specify the number of
steps needed to get from the
state to another state.
So assuming that there is a
walk from state i to i,
meaning that i is accessible
from i, it's not always true.
You might go out of i and
never come back to it.
So assuming that there's a
positive probability that we
can go from state i to i, you
can look at the number of
steps needed for this walk.
And we can find the greatest
common divisor of
this number of steps.
And it's called the
period of i.
And if this number is greater
than 1, then i is
called to be periodic.
And if it's not,
it's aperiodic.
So the very simple example
of this thing
is this Markov chain.
So probability of 1,1
in step is 0.
probability of 1, 1 in two
steps is positive.
And actually, probability of
1, 1 for all even number of
steps is positive.
But for all odd number
of steps, it's 0.
And actually, you can
prove that 2 is the
greatest common divisor.
So this is the very
easy example to
show that it's periodic.
So there is a very simple
thing to check if
something is aperiodic.
But it doesn't tell me--
I mean, if it doesn't exist, we
don't know its periodicity.
So if there is a walk from state
1 or state i to itself,
and in this walk, we go from a
state called, like, j, and
there is a loop here--
so Pjj is positive.
What can we say about the
periodicity of i?
No, the period is 1.
Yeah, exactly.
So in this case, state i
is always aperiodic.
So if there's a walk, and in
this walk, there is a loop, we
always say that.
But if it doesn't exist, can
we say anything about the
periodicity?
No.
It might be periodic.
It might be aperiodic.
It's just a check.
So whenever you see a loop,
it's aperiodic.
Whenever you see a loop in the
walk from i to i, if there's a
loop in the other side of the
Markov chain, we don't care.
So the definition is fine.
So just looking at this example,
so if we're going
from state 4 to 4, the number
of states that we need is,
like, 4, 6, 8.
So 4, 1, 2, 3, 4 is a cycle, or
is a walk from 4, to 4, and
the number of steps is 4.
4, 5, 6, 7, 8 9, 4
is another walk.
So this corresponds
to n equal to 6.
And 4, 1, 2 3, 4, 1, 2, 3,
4 is another walk which
corresponds to n equal to 8.
So you see that we can go like
this or this or this.
So these are different n's.
But we see that the greatest
common divisor is 2.
So the period of state 4 is 2.
For state 7, we have
this thing.
So the minimum number of steps
to get from 7 to itself is 6,
and then you can get from
7 to 7 in 10 steps.
And I hope you see it.
So it's going to be like this.
And so again, the greatest
common divisor is 2.
So we proved that if one state
in a class is recurrent, and
then all the states
are recurrent.
And we said that recurrency
corresponds to having a cycle,
having a walk from each
state to itself.
So this is the result, very
similar to that one, which
says that all the states
in the same class
have the same period.
And in this example,
you see it too.
The proof is not very
complicated, but it takes time
to do that.
So I'm not going to do it.
But it's all nice.
So it's good if you look at
the text, you'll see that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
only for recurrent states?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
For non-recurrent ones, it's--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's 1.
It's aperiodic.
OK, yeah.
Periodicity is only defined for
recurrent states, yeah.
We have another example here.
I just want to show you.
So I have two recurrent classes
in this example.
Actually, three.
So one of them is this class.
What is the period for a class
corresponding to state 1?
It's 1, because I have a loop.
It's very simple.
For any n, there is a positive
probability.
What is the period for
this class, states--
containing states 4 and 5?
Look at it.
There is definitely a
loop in this class.
So it's 1.
No, I said that whenever there
is a loop, the greatest common
divisor is 1.
So for going from a state 5 to
5, we can go it in one step,
two step, three step,
four step, five.
So the greatest common
divisor is 1.
So here, I showed you that if
there is a loop, then it's
definitely aperiodic, meaning
that the greatest common
divisor is 1.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] have
self-transitions [INAUDIBLE]
2?
PROFESSOR: No, I'm talking
about 4 and 5.
In what?
AUDIENCE: If they didn't
have self-transitions?
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh yeah.
It would be like this one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, definitely.
So the class containing states
2 and 3, they are periodic.
AUDIENCE: Oh, wait.
You just said [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, actually,
we can define
for transient states.
Yeah, for transient classes,
we can define periodicity,
like this case.
Yeah, why not?
This is another very important
thing that we can
do in Markov chains.
So I have a class of states
in a Markov chain,
and they are periodic.
So the period of each state in
a class is greater than 1.
And you know that all the states
in a class have the
same period.
So it means that I can partition
the class into these
subclasses, where
there is only--
OK, so--
do I have that?
I don't know.
So let's assume that
d is equal to 3.
And the whole team is the
class of states that I'm
talking about.
I can partition into three
classes, in which I only have
transitions from one of these
to the other one.
So there's no transition in
this subclass to itself.
And the only transitions
are from one
class to the next one.
So this is sort of intuitive.
So just looking at three states,
if the period is 3, I
can partition it in this way.
Or I can have it like two of
these in this case, where I
have like this.
You see?
So there's a transition from
this to these two states, and
from these two states to here,
and from here to here.
But I cannot have any transition
from here to
itself, or from here to
here, or here to here.
Just look at the text for the
proof and illustration.
But there exists this kind
of partitioning.
You should know that.
Yeah, so if I am in a class, in
a subclass, the next state
will be in the next subclass,
for sure.
So I know this subclass
in [INAUDIBLE].
And in two steps, I will be
in the other [INAUDIBLE].
So you know that the set of
classes that I can be in
state, nd plus m.
So the other definition that
you can say is that, again,
you can choose one of the
states in a class that I
talked about.
So let's say that I
choose a state 1.
And I define Sm--
Sm corresponds to
that subclass--
are all the j's where S1j.
So I told you that I will have
d classes, I can define each
class like this.
So this is all the possible
states that I can be in nd
plus m step.
So starting from state 1, in
nd plus m step, I can be in
set of classes, for some m.
So m can we big.
But anyway, I call this
the subclass number m.
So let's just talk
about something.
So I said that in order to
characterize the Markov
chains, I need to show you the
initial state or initial state
distribution.
So it can be deterministic,
like I start from some
specific state all the time,
or there can be some
distribution, like px0, meaning
that this is the
distribution that I would have
at my initial state.
I don't have it here, but using,
I think, chain rules,
we can easily find a
distribution of states at each
time instant by having the
transitional probabilities and
the initial state
distribution.
I just wrote it for you.
So for characterizing the Markov
chain, I just need to
tell you the transition
probabilities
and the initial state.
So a very good question is that,
is there any kind of
stable behavior when time goes,
like in very far future?
So I had an example here,
just looking at here.
So this is a very simple thing
that I can say about this
Markov chain.
I know that in the very far
future, there is a 0
probability that
I'm in state 6.
And you know it why?
Because any time that I am in
state 6, I will go out of it
with probability 1.
So there's no chance that
I will be there.
Or I can say that, if I start
from state 4, in very, very
far future, I will not be in
state 1, 4, or 5, for sure.
You know why?
Because there is a positive
probability of going out of
these threes states,
like here.
And then if I go out of it,
I can never come back.
So there's a chance of going
from state 4 to state 2.
And if I ever go there, I
will never come back.
So these are the statements that
I can say about the state
of behavior or the very,
very future behavior
of the Markov chain.
So the question is that, can
we always say these kind of
statements?
And what kind of statements,
actually, we can have?
And so you see that, for
example, for a state six
[INAUDIBLE]
example, I could say that the
probability of being in state
6 as n goes to infinity is 0.
So can I always have some kind
of probability distribution
over the states in the future
as n goes to infinity?
This is a very good question.
And actually, it's related to a
lot of applications that we
have for Markov chains, like
the queuing theory.
And you can have queues
for almost anything.
So one of the most fundamental
and interesting classes of
states are the states that are
called ergodic, meaning that
they are recurrent
and aperiodic.
So if I have a Markov chain that
has only one class, and
this class is recurrent and
aperiodic, then we call it a
ergodic Markov chain.
So we had two theorems saying
that if a state in a class is
recurrent, then all the
states are recurrent.
And if a state in a class is
aperiodic, then all the states
are aperiodic.
So we can say that some classes
are ergodic and some
are not ergodic.
So if the Markov chain has only
one class, and this class
is aperiodic and recurrent,
then we call it a ergodic
Markov chain.
And the very important and
nice property of ergodic
Markov chains is that they
lose memory as n goes to
infinity, meaning that whatever
initial distribution
that I have for the initial
state, I will
lose memory of that.
So whatever state that I start
in, or whatever distribution
that I start in, after a while,
for a large enough n,
the distribution of states
does not depend on that.
So again, looking at that chain
rule, I could say that I
can find the probability
distribution of x by looking
at this thing.
And looking at these
recursively, it all depends on
P of the initial distribution.
And the ergodic Markov chains
have this property that, after
a while, this distribution
doesn't depend on initial
distribution anymore.
So they lose memory.
And actually, usually we can
calculate the stable
distribution.
So this thing goes to a limit
which is called pj.
So the important thing is that
it doesn't depend on i.
It doesn't depend
where i starts.
Eventually, I will converge
the distribution.
And then this distribution
doesn't change.
So for a large enough n, I have
this property for ergodic
Markov chains.
We will have a lot
to do with these
properties in the future.
So I was saying that this pj,
pi j, should be positive.
So being in each state has
a non-0 probability.
The first thing that I need to
prove is that pijn and is
nonzero for a large enough n for
all j and all the initial
distributions.
And I want to prove that
this is true for
ergodic Markov chains.
This is not true, generally.
Well, this is more a
combinatorial issue, but there
is a theorem here which says
that for an ergodic Markov
chain, for all n greater than
this value, I have non-0
probability of going
from i to j.
So the thing that you should be
careful here is that, for
all n greater than this value.
So for going from a state 1 to
1, I can go it in six steps
and 12 steps and so on.
But I cannot go it in
24 steps, I think.
I cannot go from 1
to 1 in 25 steps.
But I can go from 1 to 1 in
26, 27, 28, 29, to 30.
So for n greater than n minus
1 squared plus 1, I can go
from any state to any state.
So I think this [? bond ?]
is tied for state 4.
Sorry, maybe what I said
is true for state 4.
Yeah.
So I'm not going to prove
this theorem.
Well, actually you don't
have the proof
in the notes, either.
But yeah, you can look at the
example and the cases that are
discussed in the notes.
Is there any questions?
Fine?